aujourd'hui ces îles paradisiaques sont
en sursis les touristes les fêtards les
marginaux et les millionnaires ils
vivent peut-être leur dernière belles
années en cause la pollution
elle détruit peu à peu la barrière de
corail de 300 km de long qui protège
l'archipel de l'érosion
résultat un tiers de ces plages est
aujourd'hui en péril
le phénomène est accentué par le
réchauffement climatique et les ouragans
de plus en plus dévastateur qui frappent
la région
face à cette catastrophe annoncée les
scientifiques tirent la sonnette
d'alarme comme Dan burdeno un jeune
océanographe de 28 ans
contre la puissance des vagues dans 50
ans tout ce quartier sera sous l'eau
c'était effrayant de penser ce qui
pourrait arriver si on perd la barrière
face à l'urgence le jeune scientifique a
décidé d'agir avec son équipe il a mis
au point un procédé révolutionnaire pour
faire pousser du corail à grande échelle
et peut-être sauver la barrière
ça c'est notre arbre à coraux quand il
est immergé dans l'eau à 5 mètres de
profondeur ça permet au coraux d'avoir
accès aux nutriments à la lumière du
soleil et aussi d'avoir assez d'espace
pour grandir les coraux adorent ce
système
ça peut paraître rudimentaire mais ce
concept ingénieux a été copié dans le
monde entier car le corail est dur à
faire pousser
c'est bon à 5 km des côtes une ferme
d'élevage sous-marine
6000 m² de corail une véritable forêt
artificielle le scientifique plongez ici
tous les jours pour surveiller la
croissance de ces 40.000 greffons c'est
la première phase de l'opération de
sauvetage ensuite il faut transplanter
les greffons sur le récif pour
consolider la barrière
ce sont des animaux qui vivent en
colonie ils prennent du calcium dans
l'eau et durant leur croissance le
transforme en pierre
et petit à petit il se développe les uns
sur les autres
et c'est ça au fil des siècles qui
forment la roche de corail et à la fin
ça fait une barrière qui nous protège
des vagues
en disant damer ses collègues ont déjà
effectué plus de 80 000 greffes à la
main sur une vingtaine de signes ils
espèrent ainsi parvenir à restaurer
totalement la barrière
[Musique]
c'est un déclin qui a eu lieu depuis 20
30 ans dans l'équipe
et chaque année cette pire en pire
nous on essaie d'inverser ce phénomène
et ça prend du temps
ici on se sent tous missionnés l'océan
c'est notre passion à tous et
actuellement l'océan est vraiment menacé
si on ne fait rien maintenant il sera
peut-être trop tard
donner son équipe ne savent pas s'ils
arriveront un jour au terme de leur
mission mais ils sont bien décidés à se
battre
à l'échelle de l'océan c'est une goutte
d'eau mais pour les Kiss de Floride et
leurs habitants une note d'espoir pour
que ce paradis tropical reste encore
longtemps l'une des destinations de
vacances préférées des Américains